stéphane noël directeur en ile-de-france
de l'établissement français du sang est
en ligne avec nos bons jours bonjour
après plus de cinquante jours de
confinement quel bilan faites-vous de
cette collecte de sang y at il une
poursuite de la mobilisation des
franciliens déjà écouté le bilan que
nous faisons de la collecte pendant suit
50 jours de confinement est un bilan
effectivement intéressant ce sens où les
franciliens se sont fortement mobilisés
à nos côtés nous avons vécu des périodes
assez difficile notamment juste après
l'annnonce du confinement total par le
président de la république où les
français de manière globale se sont
fortement interrogé quant à la
possibilité d'aller donner leur sang et
quelques jours après il ya eu un
formidable élan de générosité qui nous a
permis de faire face aux besoins des
patients puisqu'il faut le rappeler même
pendant cette période de confinement
même pendant cette période si
particulière
les malades continuent à avoir besoin de
produits sanguins il est important de
continuer à donner son sang cette
mobilisation a été très forte
elle a été très très forte pendant les
premiers jours du confinement
effectivement aujourd'hui on voit
qu'avec le temps elle commence un petit
peu à s'émousser
comment ça un petit peu à s'estomper il
est important aujourd'hui de de se
remobiliser à nouveau parce que nous
avons besoin des donneurs dans la durée
nous avons oblique aussi besoin des
personnes qui ne donne pas encore leur
sens et qui pourraient nous rejoindre et
il est important que chaque jour nous
puissions son ensemble de points de
collecte que soient nos maisons du don
où que ce soit nos collectes mobiles et
bien de voir les franciliens nous
rejoindre et venir donner leur chance
est extrêmement important comment se
passent les collectes justement
concrètement la prise de rendez vous est
conseillé ou obligatoire alors
aujourd'hui les collectes se déroule en
respectant de manière très scrupuleuse
l'ensemble des mesures pour garantir la
sécurité des donneurs et donc nous
appliquons des mesures très strictes en
matière d'hygiène des mains
nous mettons à disposition de la
solution hydroalcoolique dès l'entrée
sur le connect nous équipant chaque 2
da masque nous prenons des mesures pour
que les règles de distanciation soient
respectés aux différents stades de la
collecte
nous organisons l'étape de la collation
pour faire en sorte que le donneur soit
suffisamment distants les uns et les
autres pour garantir absolument la
sécurité de tous et oui depuis quelques
semaines nous avons mis en place un
système de rendez vous deux qui est
d'ailleurs très plébiscité par les
donneurs de la mesure où il permet
véritablement d'organiser son don du
sang est aujourd'hui pour venir sur nos
collectes et bien il est nécessaire de
prendre rendez vous et c'est très simple
bien sûr notre site internet on peut
trouver tous nos lieux de collecte
qu'ils soient fixes ou mobiles
on clique sur le lieu de collecte et de
là on accède à un lien qui nous permet
de prendre rendez vous sur un site
internet dédié un seul un site internet
qui s'affiche à l'écran je leur donne
mon en tirait rendez vous tirez donc de
sancoins fs point sante.fr voilà mais
ils s'affichent pour ceux qui voudraient
prendre rendez vous est donné sans et
plaquettes avec le déconfinement qui
s'annonce qui devrait débuter à partir
du 11 mai est-ce que les modalités vont
changer évoluer pour pouvoir donner ce
que vous allez revoir encore le
processus avec le déconfinement nous
restons extrêmement attentifs puisque
vous le savez la région ile-de-france
pour l'instant est encore classé rouge
et de ce fait les mesures de précaution
les règles de sécurité
vous restez un très haut niveau donc
tout ce que j'évoquais tout à l'heure en
matière de distanciation sociale en
matière de port du masque en matière de
d'hygiène des mains
ce sont des mesures que nous allons
maintenir et que nous allons maintenir
dans la durée
aussi longtemps qu'il sera nécessaire
pour garantir la sécurité des donneurs
et d'autre part les mesures de prise de
rendez-vous sont aussi des mesures que
nous allons maintenir dans la durée pour
garantir qu'il n'y a pas d'afflux massif
ponctuellement de donneurs et faire en
sorte que les donneurs quand ils
viennent sur une collecte
il reste le temps juste nécessaire à la
réalisation du dans le sens ni plus ni
moins et puis ces rendez vous étant
tellement plébiscité aujourd'hui par les
donneurs
et bien c'est même une mesure que nous
envisageons de pérenniser au delà du
camp en filmant parce que le permet à
tous de virtuellement s'organiser et
puis une dernière question sur la
mobilisation aussi de le ffs participent
à cette recherche autour du dico vide
peut-être nous en dire quelques mots il
ya une mobilisation aussi
alors effectivement l'établissement
français du sang participent à une
recherche sur un protocole que nous
appelons corrie place mme il s'agit
d'utiliser du plasma que nous prélevons
chez des potes donneurs qui sont des
patients qu'ovide convalescent en
espérant que les anticorps qui ont été
développés par ces patients ne puissent
permettre à des patients aujourd'hui
hospitalisé 2 faire face aux que vit
donc ses travaux sont actuellement en
cours
nous sommes très mobilisés en
ile-de-france pour re prélever du plasma
chez des patients convalescent de la
mesure où nous sommes l'un des
principaux bassins de deux malades du
cog vide et nous espérons obtenir dans
les prochaines semaines les résultats de
cet essai clinique
donc c'est un essai qui est menée de
manière extrêmement rigoureuse et nous
souhaitons attendre les conclusions
définitives de cet essai avant de
communiquer sur les résultats
merci beaucoup stéphane noël directeur
de l'établissement français du sang en
ile-de-france d'avoir été en ligne avec
nos aujourd'hui merci à vous merci